私は tear 目の力を押しました
インターネットで原因を追究して改名しようと思ったりしてます
毎日毎日
職場に行けなくなった自分を下げました
しかしっ
優等生だった私が今まで身につけてきたものでは
まったく解決できませんでした
それどころか
自分を責めれば責めるほど
いける力が失われていくのん
今まですべてうまくいっているような気がしてきた
いっ
あんなに努力もした
一番どん底だった時はん
と彼らのことも考えて怒っ
でもへ
結局結局私は生きたいってその時思ったんです
こんな私でも
この先も強く生きていきたいって言っ
思ったんです
命がけで見つけ出した一番大切だったもの
勉強がんばるっ
その前に
完璧にするこ
よその前
じゃあ4章きれいする
その前
自分の心が笑っていること
だったのです
皆さんの心は今笑ってますか
自分の元って好きですか
心は人間が皆平等に持っています
でも人によって感じ方も違うしその先の人生も違います
ちょっとそんなことがわかる面白いことをやってみましょう
どんなシーンだと思いますか
喧嘩してるし
協力して相談してるし
実はこの会では何も意味なんてないんです
五歳の子が見たら何も感じないかもしれません
そういった何も意味のないえお
皆さんが各自の捉え方というメガネ応答して見ています
今もそうです私のことを選んでいます
井戸によって捉え方が違います
そしてその捉え方によって
その先の感情や行動が大きく左右されます
例えば
先ほどの絵を受け
あ
kenta 捨てるシーンだと思ったっ
ああそういえば私も弟へ旦那さんと喧嘩したなんてっ
あれは時と謝ってくれてないじゃない
ボイヤー今日の夕飯館プラン年でだったりとか
そんな経験ありませんか
んですかねぇ
えっ
そんなふうに自分の捉え方によって繁盛や行動が多く対応します
では一体
捉え方のメガネそれでいつ作られると思いますか
皆さんをかけているその苗がではダン年前でことですか
何年産のものですか
実は
幼い頃の大人との関わりの中でほとんどが作られると言われています
例えば幼い頃から暴力を受けて育った人に対して行
突然手を上げるぞ
いくとするかもしれません
と怖い経験があったのでしょう
でも何も感じないと思います私が入って手を挙げると向こうから市の茶
配達して元たりとかするかもしれません
人によって捉え方が本当に違います
では
その捉え方
皆さんの捉え方はいつ作られたと思いますか
あなたのかけているその女がでは残念さんですか
私は
幼い頃の経験でそ
まさしく作られていました
幼い頃に
勉強ができるぞ
しのちゃんすごいね埋められてっ
完璧にすると
長ら有望だねーってー
褒められてい
努力根性人大まじめ完璧成績メガネっ
今考えるととても重くて大きい眼鏡のような気がする
そういったメガネを
自分の命と同じくらい大切にしてきました
でも苦しかったんです
そしたらいったん外してもいい
違うものに作り変えることもできたんです
私は
自分がボードこの時に結婚しました
新婚だと言う
私はもう駄目な人間だっ
どうやって来ていったらいいのかわからないん
毎日毎日ないって旦那さん言っていまし
そしたら旦那さんは
そのままでもいいよ
誰も悪くないからー
ゆっくり休んでいいんだよと
私はびっくりしました
もっと頑張れとかこうしてみればっていうんじゃないんだ
初めはすごく違和感を感じていましたか
繰り返し繰り返し聞いているうちに村かもって思ってくるんです
私ってええ
なにか出来るから家がある
の価値があるんじゃない
何もできなくてもそのままでも
し生きていても
いいんじゃないの価値があるんじゃないのって徐々に思うようになってきた
そしたら心がふっと軽くなりました
ちょっと今までかけてきた
その古い眼鏡を外すことができたとかっ
あって子供の必要がなくなったから
今のわたしでも何もできない私でもいいんでしょうってえっ
あれがかけてくれたその言葉にはどんな秘密が隠されていました
あればいい
中学校の時に不登校でしたっ
学校に行けなくなってボロボロになった彼に対して
お母さんが言ってくれたそうですね
そのままでもいいよ
悪くないから
学校休んでもいいよいい
幼い頃の彼は
毎日毎日自分を責めていました
思っ
そのお母さんから言われる言葉を繰り返し繰り返し聞いているうちに
に徐々に心が笑い始めたそうです
をして
私をつくってくれた加江田今います
どん底だった時に
私や彼が掛けてもらったん
そのままでもいいよ何も悪くないからゆっくり休んでいいんだよという言葉は
あなたはそのままでも100点だよ
生きてるだけで100点満点なんだよって言う
命の憲法体を表したものだったのです
彼はお母さんがラムがもらった無償の愛の稼働を大
私に渡してくれたのです
それも無意識の中でです
ちょっと実感ができることをやってみたいと思います
今から私が言う言葉を大変な人から言われてると思って想像してみてください
頭の中にその人の顔を覚えられてもわかりやすいかなと思います
だからっ
あなたはダメな人間さん
もっと丸バエもっともっと本願じゃダメっ
年で購入してみればいいじゃん私これがうまくいったから投入してみたら
そうなんでダメ
仕事休むの学校やサブの
そんなの絶対だめだ待っていて
でも散らせますか
ああああああ
あなたは今のままで大丈夫
そのままで大丈夫だよ
疲れたら休んでもいいんだよ
あなたは
生きてるだけで価値がある100点満点なんだから
そのままで大丈夫
疲れたら休んでもいい4位
大丈夫だよ
そんな気持ちがしますか
言葉は言霊です
行けるだけで100点満点
この言葉こそ
愛をがトーン追う
私ていく言葉じゃないのかなと私は思います
私は終わりました
だって生きてるだけで100点満点なんだっ
勇気や希望が持てました
して初めてうっ
初めて自分らしさを手に入れなんです
私は26歳のブー
自分らしい眼鏡をかけて再度教壇に立ちました
5年生のクラスの担任です
明るくってとっても心が優しい子たちでした
私は
前からもらった庄内の花と桜
毎日毎日子どもたちに渡していきました
みんなそのままでも十分すごいよ
未来生きてるだけで100点なんだよ
そんなこともできたのをすごいねえっ
毎日毎日ひとりー
大切に渡していきました
そうした子どもたちの表情がどんどん明るくなって
ちまう編成だっていた
先生のプラスで本当に良かった
先生と出会いでよかったって伝え関してくれる
さらには
先生僕ね本なものができたんだよ
先生私ね実は本当は雇用もんってだろう
心を開いて話してくれるようになりました
7月の初めの頃には時世なら作法にしたばっかり向いていた
そんな子が3学期の最後には友達と
版頑張って声をあげてっ
顔を上げて笑うようになりました
はたちは子どもたちの命がー
輝いていくのを感じました
人は
自分の命が全肯定されて初めて
自分らしいあなたらしいそしてその子たちらしい
捉え方の命がけができます
自分らしく生きること
これがなによりも幸せではないでしょうか
私はひとりでも多くの人が
愛のバトンを手にして欲しいです
自分の人生を自分らしく
自信を持って歩んでいってほしいです
そして期待でいってほしい
親が親から子へ
あなたは来てる中にやってんだよそのままでいいよ
先生から制度へ
みんなーそのままでも十分すごいんだよ
自分から
主はあなたがいるだけで幸せなよっ
生きてるだけで100点満点
今日からこの言葉をたくさん言霊にいて欲しいと思います
たくさんの人に伝えていってほしいなというふうに思います
大人顔どもに伝えればそのこともはいつで大人になります
そうしたら
幼い恋自分が大人からされたように
子どもたちにするんです
だから
大人たちが
自分は言ってるだけで100点なんだってっ
自分で思えることそれがとっても退社
最後に
今日
エアーと皆さんに私から愛のバトンを渡したいと思います
皆さんご
何か辛いことがあったりするかもしれないけれどもそのままで大丈夫です
弾いてるだけで100点満点です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]